the title of the April issue is water
our thirsty world this is called the
layout room we put the whole issue on
the wall full size it's ironic that so
many pictures actually art of places
with a lot of water they're places
without water it's a special issue a
single topic issue that we're doing when
we do them every couple of years I think
the thing that that we want to do more
than anything else
in this issue is illustrate how
incredibly precious water is the water
issue to me when I heard they were done
any showing water I thought this is the
best issue that Jim ever can ever do
this isn't like an emergency situation
because then all the traveling and all
the other stories I do I think that
topic comes up a lot like where they get
in water and is it clean and no it isn't
when found her way to these places that
had the problems nobody's in there
solving them so then you get it it's
more wrong we're looking at how people
live and we're sort of checking in at a
particular moment in time and trying to
get people the big picture so much of
the world's freshwater is locked up in
glaciers and there's whole civilizations
live off of the reliability about water
coming from those glaciers that
reliability is being threatened
Palestinian farmers have been there for
a long time can only drill their wells
50 meters deep whereas Israeli
settlements just next door can go down
150 meters Paulo has images of people
that are surviving on just a couple
liters of water a day it's a bad pun but
water can be a dry subject too if it
just becomes all issues every religion
has something that relates to water in
the religion in a purifying cleansing
blessing sort of way so we wanted to
include that in the issue
most freshwater species are incredibly
threatened and things are going so fast
we don't even know what we're losing you
need to stop and think about what you're
doing to this water supply we're all
trying to figure out what to do next
about climate change and the lack of
water and the lack of clean water and
how we've eaten all the fish water is
one of those very important things that
we take for granted and we tend not to
appreciate it until we don't have
water sustains life what I would like is
for our photographs to make you stop and
think and appreciate